well it's starting to feel a little more
like the holidays clear skies have
cooled us
off and there's one thing you might want
to put on your calendar if you don't
already know about it and it's the
geminids meteor shower
which peaks this weekend it's one of the
best meteor shower shows of the year
50 to 100 or more meteors per hour
with the moonless sky this year that's
sunday night at the peak but the problem
is
may have too many clouds in the sky
we'll see how mother nature sends those
clouds our way and how many are left on
sunday we have a couple of systems
coming in one today
and another one again late on sunday
evening
so 37 at mountains edge with clear skies
nellis you're down to freezing
aliante at 38 centennial hills summerlin
you're in the low 40s
yesterday the rain in utah in
arizona actually ended the dry spells
for phoenix and yuma
snow up into utah and over into colorado
look at albuquerque got snow
rain thunderstorms all of that we missed
out on all of that nice rain we needed
it and snow in our mountains
so we've got clouds coming in now with
the next system and there's yet another
one out there in the pacific which will
affect us
sunday and cool us down even more today
upper 50s
a little north breeze but more wind up
in the mountains today so be careful up
there
we'll look for more sunshine in between
this system and sundays
tomorrow 60 degrees mostly sunny clouds
come in later
again sunday into sunday night 53 on
sunday look at those mornings in the 30s
it's going to chill down for sure
and then upper 50s to near 60 next week
with mostly sunny skies 6